die niedersächsische stadt winsen an der
luhe hat ihr herz für berufspendler
entdeckt direkt am bahnhof hat sie
dieses schicke parkhaus gebaut doch mit
dem prestige objekt gibt es von anfang
an probleme
7,6 millionen euro sollte es einmal
kosten fast elf millionen sind es
geworden und jetzt will hier kaum einer
parken auf fast allen ebenen herrscht
gähnende leere
die alle sind sauer hier das ist kein
wunder das geld wird rausgeschmissen und
passiert nichts
dies das geld nie wieder ein was da raus
gegangen ist das ist ein absoluter
planungsfehler es ist ein witz dass man
für so viel geld ein parkhaus gebaut und
sich da keiner rein stellt das auto ins
parkhaus am bahnhof stellen und mit dem
zug ins nach hamburg fahren die idee ist
nicht neu macht aber sinn
doch im winsener projekt ist wahrhaftig
der wurm drin
kurz nach baubeginn stößt man auf
altlasten dann gibt es probleme mit dem
grundwasser und schließlich sagt eine
lärmschutzwand ab die kosten explodieren
nach fast zwei jahren bauzeit ist das
parkhaus seit anfang april geöffnet und
seitdem steht der park and ride tempel
fast komplett leer
von den 500 40 stellplätzen sind gerade
mal 100 vermietet 290 euro pro jahr
kostet ein platz dass es den meisten
autofahrern schlicht zu teuer da packten
viele ihren wagen lieber woanders
nämlich kostenfrei auf der anderen seite
des bahnhofs der gut gemeinte plan droht
zum teuren millionen flop zu werden doch
im rathaus lässt man sich von so was
nicht aus der ruhe bringen schriftlich
heißt es eine zunehmende inanspruchnahme
des parkhauses ist unter anderem
deswegen zu erwarten weil die
befristeten ausweichparkplätze nach und
nach wieder verschwinden eine
verbesserung der auslastungszahlen wird
sich durch verstärktes marketing
erreichen lassen was die stadt nun plant
ist allerdings keine populäre werbung
fürs parkhaus erstmal wird das
kostenlose parken drumherum
eingeschränkt
hier machen wir jetzt überall absolutes
halteverbot damit sie die park ride
parkhaus folge
das ist eine sauerei wenn ich etwas
bezahlen muss ist parken reiche leute
fahren lieber eine station weiter weil
wir dort für das fahrzeug nichts
bezahlen und für die beförderung
bezahlen sie dort weniger einen bahnhof
weiter in ashausen sind die park and
ride stellplätze kostenlos da
funktioniert es in winsen an der luhe
sieht es zur gleichen zeit so aus da
kann man nur die daumen drücken dass das
teure parkhaus nicht doch noch zum
millionengrab wird